die weltweite nachfrage nach
kraftfahrzeugen wird eine million nicht
überschreiten allein schon aus mangel an
verfügbaren shop hören
es wird nie eine flugmaschine geben die
von paris nach new york fliegt
ich glaube es gibt einen weltweiten
bedarf an vielleicht fünf computern
letzte woche habe ich in diesem video
darüber gesprochen welche technologien
und erfindungen das kommende jahrzehnt
prägen werben heute wollen wir uns
einmal ansehen was in der vergangenheit
über die zukunft gedacht wurde und warum
eine genaue vorhersage eigentlich
unmöglich ist denn wir können
tatsächlich eine menge lernen wenn wir
den blick einmal auf das lenken was
wissenschaftler und experten in der
vergangenheit über die aktuelle zeit die
damalige zukunft gedacht haben
gegen ende des 19 jahrhunderts wurde
eine gruppe französischer künstler damit
beauftragt ihre vorstellungen für eine
welt in hundert jahren zu illustrieren
unter anderem diese bilder sind es die
dabei herauskamen
wie ihr seht hat es damals vor allem das
fliegen die automatisierung menschlicher
prozesse und das leben unter wasser eine
starke faszination auf die künstler
ausgeübt und wie sieht es heute aus
das jahr 2000 ist nun inzwischen schon
20 jahre her
und auch wenn einige konzepte doch etwas
abgedreht zu sein scheinen sind ein paar
grundlegende ideen heute längst realität
fahren nur häuser zum beispiel fliegende
feuerbekämpfung und automatisierte putz
maschinen und erntehelfer sind nur ein
paar beispiele ebenfalls futuristisch
aber noch näher an der heutigen realität
waren die vorstellungen 40 jahre später
nämlich bei der weltausstellung 1939 in
new york die große depression sei es den
amerikanern noch tief in den knochen und
man wollte den besuchern einen einblick
in eine schönere welt ermöglichen eine
welt die hoffentlich bald realität
werden sollte
das motto war the world of tomorrow die
welt von morgen unternehmen aus 33
ländern zeigten stolz ihre vision der
zukunft
dazu gehörten futuristische konzepte wie
geschirrspüler und fax maschinen genauso
wie der fernseher aber auch eine kuh
melkanlage mit angeschlossener softeis
produktion
klingt praktisch doch auch die stadt der
zukunft spielt eine zentrale rolle
general motors präsentierte einvernommen
bildes entwickeltes verkehrskonzept das
vier spuren des super highways mit
intelligenten verkehrssteuerung systemen
versprach so sollte der mensch der
zukunft effizient und schnell durch die
riesigen megacities transportiert werden
einer der höhepunkte der ausstellung war
jedoch der von westinghouse präsentierte
roboter namens elektro dieser war in der
lage sind kommandos auszuführen zu
zählen und wie sich für ein roboter von
welt gehörte zigarette zu rauchen
und auch wenn wir heute mancherorts
immer noch auf überfüllten autobahnen
stehen in der stadt auf verspätete
bahnen warten und unsere zigaretten
weiterhin selbst rauchen müssen sind
doch viele der dort andachten konzepte
bald wirklichkeit geworden
es scheint also als wäre es durchaus
möglich die zukunft vorherzusehen
oder klappt dafür aber den termin
festgelegt
okay vielleicht funktioniert doch nicht
immer so wie man es gerne hätte
die experten dieser welt liegen
tatsächlich gar nicht so selten komplett
daneben selbst wenn sie über ihre
eigenen projekte sprechen und wenn wir
uns die bisher genannten vision einmal
genauer ansehen erkennt man dass auch
hier nicht immer alles gold ist was
glänzt
die französischen künstler des 19
jahrhunderts lagen zwar an so mancher
stelle richtig aber vergleicht man die
erwarteten maschinen mit den heutigen
dann merkt man schnell dass der
wichtigste aspekt der letzten 50 jahre
komplett fehlt die digitalisierung die
ausgeführten prozesse sind zwar bereits
automatisiert dennoch sind sie nicht
autonom und in jedem fall noch
mechanisch es wird immer ein mensch
benötigt der die maschine überwacht und
steuert die zukunftsvorstellungen der
künstler zeigen die relativ allgemeinen
wünsche und sehnsüchte der menschheit
schon leonardo da vinci plante ein
fluggerät dass es den menschen erlauben
sollte selbst die lüfte zu erkunden und
spätestens seit der industrialisierung
arbeiten wir mit hochdruck daran die
lästigen prozesse des alltags zu
automatisieren was die faszination einer
unterwasserwelt angeht nun gut da
scheinen wir hingegen etwas den fokus
verloren zu haben wir reiten tatsächlich
heute nicht auf seepferdchen und spielen
auch nicht unter wasser trickett
stattdessen zieht es uns mittlerweile
immer weiter von der erde weg aber auch
die raumfahrt spielt in den
illustrationen überhaupt keine rolle
es scheint so als hätte man damals nicht
über den tellerrand hinausschauen können
alle vorstellungen waren zwar
futuristisch aber eben auch nur
futuristische versionen von dingen die
es bereits gab
man konnte zwar weiter denken aber
nichts wirklich neues er denken
doch wie steht es denn nun um die
experten dieser welt sind vorhersagen
wirklich so schwierig wie so treffen
selbst profis wie daimler reiht und
watson so anscheinend unüberlegte
aussagen
die drei sind nämlich nicht einmal die
einzigen promis die durch solche
fehlprognosen hervorstechen
lord kelvin namensgeber der temperatur
einheit und seinerzeit präsident der
royal society war der ansicht fluggeräte
die schwerer sind als luft werde es
niemals geben und nannte
röntgenstrahlung einen hoax also einen
schwindel auch professor ernst macht
nachdem die macht zahl benannt wurde
verewigte sich mit dem kühnen satz ich
glaube nicht an atome
und selbst albert einstein himself man
sich sicher dass es nicht den geringsten
hinweis darauf gebe dass kernenergie
jemals nutzbar sein würde sagt niemals
nie klingt an dieser stelle nach einer
ziemlich sinnvollen hilfestellung und
tatsächlich kommen wir dem kern des
problems damit relativ nah wenn etwas
nicht gerade physikalisch unmöglich ist
dann kann man davon ausgehen dass die
menschheit erst irgendwann erfinden wird
auch wenn es im moment noch überhaupt
nicht danach aussieht
gleichzeitig ist natürlich klar dass wir
berühmte leute zitieren die diese
falschen vorhersagen getroffen haben
wenn sich albert einstein hinstellt und
etwas so endgültiges prognostiziert dann
ist es natürlich gefundenes fressen für
die medien
doch wieso ist es selbst für die
klügsten köpfe der welt so schwierig
zukünftige entwicklungen vorherzusagen
um das zu verstehen müssen wir uns
folgendes phänomen ansehen nämlich die
chaostheorie kleinste einwirkungen auf
ein system können in der summe der durch
die folgenden reaktionen riesige
auswirkungen haben die chaostheorie fußt
auf denen durch isaac newton gegen ende
des 16 jahrhunderts aufgestellten
grundgesetzen der bewegung durch diese
gesetze ist es in der theorie möglich
alles erdenkliche vorherzusagen wenn ich
nur die ausgangspunkte und die
geschwindigkeiten aller atome in einem
geschlossenen system kenne man kann
nicht in zukunft einfach berechnen
mit diesem wissen ließ der meteorologe
edward lorenz 1963 eine
computersimulation zur wettervorhersage
durchführen
dazu gab er neben einigen konstanten
auch variable werkzeugen wie zum
beispiel temperatur luftdruck oder
luftfeuchtigkeit ein um die erhaltenen
ergebnisse zu überprüfen startete einen
neuen durchlaufen mit denselben werten
bis auf eine einzige ausnahme
anstelle der zahl 0,5 06127 nutzte er
für die simulation nur 0,5 06 und auch
wenn der unterschied dieses wertes
minimal erscheint sorgt er im verlaufe
der simulation dafür dass schon nach
kurzer zeit komplett andere
wetterbedingungen herrschten lorenz
stellt überrascht fest dass es sich
nicht um einen fehler des computers
handelte sondern dass selbst die
kleinsten änderungen maßgebliche
auswirkungen auf simulationen eines
systems haben können er erkannte dass
unser deterministische system von chaos
beherrscht wird so entstand der heute
aus film und fernsehen bekannte
schmetterlingseffekt selbst die
kleinsten änderungen an einer stelle
können riesige auswirkungen
an einer anderen stelle bewirken
angewandt auf unsere frage danach ob es
denn nun möglich ist die zukunft
vorherzusagen bedeutet dass theoretisch
ja praktisch leider nein
es ist zwar möglich prozesse wie zum
beispiel die bewegung der planeten um
unsere sonne vorherzusagen
doch würden mehrere simulationen mit den
geringsten abweichungen irgendwann sehr
unterschiedliche verläufe anzeigen
man müsste ihnen nur genug zeit lassen
welcher dieser vorläufer dann derjenige
ist der tatsächlich eintrifft ist
unmöglich vorherzusagen
okay die zukunft genau vorhersagen ist
nicht wirklich machbar
dennoch wird es immer wieder versucht
mal mit mehr mal mit weniger erfolg
und je nachdem wie man es betrachtet ist
es sogar trotz chaos theorie möglich auf
gewisse art und weise zukünftige
entwicklungen vorherzusagen
dabei müssen jedoch ein paar dinge
beachtet werden man sollte zum beispiel
experte auf dem gebiet seien über das
man prognosen anstellen will um
möglichst viele der variablen
einschätzen zu können
man sollte außerdem versuchen nicht zu
weit in die zukunft zu blicken da die
abweichungen durch den
schmetterlingseffekt mit mehr zeit immer
deutlicher werden und man sollte seine
prognose nicht zur einzigen wahrheit
erklären und stattdessen einen gewissen
interpretationsspielraum lassen
so können unvorhersehbare abweichungen
mit einbezogen werden
bei unseren recherchen sind wir auf eine
umfrage des australischen senders abc
aus dem jahre 2010 gestoßen die dort
befragten wissenschaftler haben
tatsächlich alles richtig gemacht und
deswegen die zukunft ziemlich präzise
vorhergesagt
sie wurden über ihre prognosen für das
jahr 2020 befragt und sollten jeweils
einen ausblick über die entwicklungen
ihrer fachbereiche geben
interessant ist dass ihre aussagen in
den meisten fällen keine revolutionären
fortschritte vorhersagen sie können aber
gerade deswegen gut mit der
tatsächlichen entwicklung in einklang
gebracht werden
eine besonders faszinierende neue
entdeckungen die es in den nächsten zehn
jahren zu genießen gilt könnt ihr die
herkunft der masse sein wenn der large
hadron collider das higgs boson
identifiziert neue maschinen die
terabyte an genetischen informationen
liefern können machen es möglich dass
jeder seine gesamte dna in weniger als
einer woche für 1000 dollar sequenzieren
lässt theoretisch könnten diese
informationen verwendet werden um
krankheiten und krebs und adipositas
jahre im voraus vorherzusagen wenn sie
sich tatsächlich entwickeln
wir sehen den aufbau von
dreidimensionalen gewebe im labor wie
haug doppelherz und knochengewebe
wachsende organe in petrischalen wenn
sie wollen aber wenn wir ansätze und
technologien die im nächsten jahrzehnt
eindeutig nicht nachhaltig sind nicht
hinter uns lassen sind die aussichten
für die zukunft der menschlichen
zivilisation sehr düster die zukunft
vorherzusagen ist also begrenzt möglich
durch die fülle an möglichen variablen
ist es allerdings selbst für die
klügsten köpfe schwierig langfristig
genaue prognosen abzugeben
und trotzdem liegt es der wissenschaft
im blut immer wieder neugierig zu machen
auf das was da noch kommen mag
und wenn man versucht sich nicht zu weit
aus dem fenster zu lehnen und seine
aussagen nicht als die ultimative
wahrheit zu verkaufen dann scheinen
prognosen für die zukunft doch keine
sache der unmöglichkeit zu sein
und wer weiß vielleicht wird das erste
doktor watson video im jahre 2030
bereits von einer community auf dem mars
gesehen
möglich wäre aber was haltet ihr davon
wie sinnvoll ist es auch sagen über die
zukunft zu treffen wenn selbst die
kleinsten variablen eine so große
auswirkungen auf den ausgang dieser
zukunft haben können
schreiben sie mir gerne unten in die
kommentare und ansonsten frohes neues
jahr 2020
herzlich willkommen in der zukunft ich
hoffe wir sehen uns dieses jahr häufiger
wieder auf diesem kanal in diesem sinne
bleibt neugierig
[Musik]